ยินดีต้อนรับกลับมาสู่การทำความเข้าใจข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ ผมชื่อ John watus และผมเป็นผู้อำนวยการเทคนิคด้านการศึกษา
ที่ IBM Quantum นี่เป็นบทเรียนที่เก้าของซีรีส์ และเป็นบทเรียนแรกในหน่วยที่สาม ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ
สูตรทั่วไปของข้อมูลควอนตัม จนถึงตอนนี้เราใช้สูตรแบบง่าย
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม ที่สถานะควอนตัมแสดงด้วยเวกเตอร์จำนวนเชิงซ้อนที่มีนอร์มแบบยูคลิเดียนเท่ากับ
หนึ่ง ในทางตรงกันข้าม ในสูตรทั่วไปของข้อมูลควอนตัม สถานะควอนตัมแสดงด้วย
เมทริกซ์ประเภทหนึ่งที่เรียกว่าเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น บทเรียนแรกของหน่วยนี้เน้นที่เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นโดยเฉพาะ
แล้วเราจะไปดูว่ามันคืออะไรและทำงานยังไง เมื่อบทเรียนดำเนินต่อไป เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นมีประโยชน์มาก
และมันมีข้อดีหลายอย่างที่เราจะพูดถึง มันช่วยให้เราแสดง
สถานะที่กว้างกว่าที่เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมทำได้ รวมถึงสถานะของระบบที่ถูกกระทบจากสัญญาณรบกวน เช่นเดียวกับการสุ่มเลือก
สถานะควอนตัม เราจะดู Block sphere ด้วย ซึ่งให้วิธีทางเรขาคณิตที่ดีมาก
และเรียบง่ายในการคิดเกี่ยวกับสถานะ qubit แล้วเราจะเห็นว่ามันเชื่อมโยงกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นยังไง
อย่างน่าทึ่งผ่านเมทริกซ์ Pauli สุดท้ายเราจะพูดถึงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นในบริบทของหลายระบบ
และโดยเฉพาะเราจะเห็นว่ามันช่วยให้เราอธิบายสถานะควอนตัมของระบบที่มองแบบแยกเดี่ยวได้ แม้ว่า
มันจะมีความสัมพันธ์กับระบบอื่น และนั่นรวมถึงความเป็นไปได้ที่มันจะพัวพันกับระบบอื่นด้วย นี่เป็นสิ่งสำคัญที่ต้อง
ทำได้ และมันทำได้ไม่ง่ายในสูตรแบบง่ายของข้อมูลควอนตัม นี่คือภาพรวมของ
บทเรียน เราจะเริ่มจากพื้นฐานของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น รวมถึงนิยามที่เกี่ยวข้องและตัวอย่างบางอย่าง แล้วเราจะ
พูดถึงว่ามันเชื่อมโยงกับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมยังไง จากนั้นเราจะพูดถึงการรวมแบบนูนของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ
จะเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อเราเอาค่าเฉลี่ยแบบถ่วงน้ำหนักของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น เราจะเริ่มด้วยตัวอย่าง
เฉพาะของสิ่งที่เรียกว่าสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ เราจะเห็นว่าสถานะความน่าจะเป็นแบบคลาสสิกสามารถมองเป็น
กรณีพิเศษของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นได้ แล้วเราจะพูดถึงว่าทฤษฎีบทสเปกตรัลจากพีชคณิตเชิงเส้นเข้ามาเกี่ยวข้องยังไง
ในบริบทนี้ ส่วนที่สามของบทเรียนเกี่ยวกับ Block sphere ซึ่งให้วิธีทางเรขาคณิตในการดูสถานะของ
qubit เดี่ยว อย่างที่บอกไว้ตอนต้นบทเรียน และในส่วนที่สี่ของบทเรียน เราจะพูดถึงว่าเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นทำงานยังไงกับหลายระบบ
เราจะพูดถึงสถานะผลคูณและสถานะที่มีความสัมพันธ์ประเภทต่างๆ รวมถึงสถานะพัวพัน รวมถึง
แนวคิดของสถานะลดรูป ซึ่งเป็นการอธิบายเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของสถานะส่วนที่แยกออกมาของระบบรวม
ที่สามารถคำนวณได้โดยใช้การดำเนินการที่เรียกว่า partial trace ก่อนที่เราจะเข้าสู่เนื้อหาทางเทคนิคของบทเรียน
ควรใช้เวลาสักครู่เพื่อให้แรงจูงใจในการใช้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น โดยใช้สูตร
แบบง่ายของข้อมูลควอนตัม ซึ่งไม่เกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น เราสามารถอธิบายอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมอย่าง
อัลกอริทึมการแยกตัวประกอบของ Shor ได้โดยไม่มีปัญหา แล้วทำไมเราต้องสนใจเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
หรือสูตรทั่วไปของข้อมูลควอนตัมด้วยล่ะ ก็มีหลายเหตุผล อย่างแรก เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
แสดงสถานะควอนตัมที่กว้างกว่าเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม รวมถึงสถานะควอนตัมที่เรามีความไม่แน่นอนหรือ
ความสุ่ม นี่สำคัญเมื่อเราต้องการจำลองผลกระทบของสัญญาณรบกวนต่อการคำนวณควอนตัม
เป็นต้น อย่างที่สอง การใช้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น เราสามารถอธิบายสถานะควอนตัมของส่วนที่แยกออกมาของระบบรวม เช่น
สถานะของระบบที่พัวพันกับระบบอื่นที่บางทีเราเลือกที่จะไม่สนใจชั่วคราว อย่างที่บอกไว้ตอนต้น
บทเรียน นี่ทำได้ไม่ง่ายหรือไม่เป็นธรรมชาติในสูตรแบบง่ายของข้อมูล
ควอนตัม เหตุผลที่สามคือเมื่อเราใช้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น ข้อมูลคลาสสิกจะกลายเป็น
กรณีพิเศษ แทนที่จะมีสิ่งที่เป็นการเปรียบเทียบระหว่างสถานะความน่าจะเป็นและการดำเนินการ
ด้านหนึ่ง กับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมและการดำเนินการแบบยูนิทารีอีกด้านหนึ่ง เรามีข้อมูลควอนตัมและคลาสสิก
ถูกอธิบายรวมกันในกรอบทางคณิตศาสตร์เดียว ซึ่งจำเป็นมากสำหรับการศึกษาทางคณิตศาสตร์
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม ดังนั้นถ้าจริงจังกับการเข้าใจข้อมูลควอนตัมในระดับคณิตศาสตร์ ก็แนะนำอย่างยิ่ง
ให้เรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น มาเริ่มจากนิยามของเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่นกัน เพื่อนิยาม สมมติว่า X คือระบบ และ sigma คือเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของมัน และจำไว้ว่า
เมื่อเราใช้คำนี้ สมมติฐานของเราคือ Sigma เป็นเซตจำกัดและไม่ว่าง และเหมือนเดิมเราสามารถเลือก
ชื่ออื่นได้ถ้าต้องการ เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่อธิบายสถานะของระบบ X คือเมทริกซ์ที่มี
สมาชิกเป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อน ที่แถวและคอลัมน์ถูกจับคู่กับเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของมัน และให้ชัดเจน
การจับคู่เดียวกันใช้กับแถวและคอลัมน์พร้อมกัน นี่หมายความว่าเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์จัตุรัสเสมอ และนอกจากจะเป็นจัตุรัสแล้ว ยังมีเงื่อนไขสองข้อที่ต้อง
เป็นไปตาม แล้วเราจะพูดถึงในอีกสักครู่ คนส่วนใหญ่ใช้อักษรกรีกตัวเล็กบางตัวเพื่อตั้งชื่อเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่น rho มักเป็นตัวเลือกแรก และตัวเลือกอื่นที่พบบ่อย ได้แก่ sigma ตัวเล็กและ tai ที่แสดงบน
หน้าจอ นี่เป็นแค่ข้อตกลง แต่เหมือนเดิม ข้อตกลงพวกนี้มีประโยชน์เพราะทำให้จำแนกได้
ง่ายขึ้น และตอนนี้มาพูดถึงเงื่อนไขหรือข้อกำหนดที่เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นต้องเป็นไปตาม เพื่อเป็น
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่ถูกต้อง มีสองข้อ และสิ่งที่จะทำคือลิสต์มันก่อน
แล้วค่อยพูดรายละเอียดว่ามันหมายความว่ายังไง เงื่อนไขแรกคือเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่นต้องมี trace เท่ากับหนึ่ง หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ trace เท่ากับหนึ่ง และเงื่อนไขที่สองคือ
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นต้องเป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอน และในทั้งสองกรณี เรามีวิธีเขียนเชิงสัญลักษณ์สั้นๆ
สำหรับสองเงื่อนไขนี้ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ตอนนี้ขอพูดรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับสองเงื่อนไขนี้
เงื่อนไขแรกหมายถึง trace ซึ่งเป็นฟังก์ชันสำคัญมากที่นิยามสำหรับเมทริกซ์จัตุรัสทุกตัว
และมันก็แค่ผลรวมของสมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุม และนี่คือสมการที่แสดงมัน
อย่างชัดเจน มีเรื่องมากมายที่จะพูดเกี่ยวกับ trace และทำไมมันสำคัญ แต่ตอนนี้ขอสังเกต
คุณสมบัติพื้นฐานอย่างหนึ่งของมัน คือมันเป็นฟังก์ชันเชิงเส้น คุณสมบัติอื่นๆ ของ trace จะเข้ามาและเราจะพูดถึง
เมื่อจำเป็น แต่เพื่อให้โฟกัสที่เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น ไปต่อที่เงื่อนไขที่สองกัน และเงื่อนไขนั้นคือ
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นต้องเป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอน นี่เป็นแนวคิดสำคัญที่ปรากฏในหลายสถานการณ์ใน
ฟิสิกส์ เคมี การหาค่าเหมาะสุด การเรียนรู้ของเครื่อง และวิชาอื่นๆ และมันสามารถแสดงได้หลายวิธีที่ต่างกันแต่
เทียบเท่ากัน วิธีหนึ่งในการแสดงคือบอกว่าเมทริกซ์ rho เป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอนถ้ามีเมทริกซ์ M
ที่ rho เท่ากับ M แด็กเกอร์คูณ M และมันปรากฏว่าไม่สำคัญว่าเราจะกำหนดให้ M เป็น
เมทริกซ์จัตุรัสหรือเราจะยกเลิกข้อจำกัดนั้น อีกวิธีในการแสดงว่าเมทริกซ์ rho เป็นกึ่งบวก
แน่นอนคือบอกว่า rho เป็นเอร์มิเชียน ซึ่งหมายความว่ามันเท่ากับสังยุคทรานสโพสของตัวเอง และ
ค่าไอเกนทั้งหมดเป็นจำนวนจริงที่ไม่ติดลบ โดยทั่วไปเมทริกซ์เอร์มิเชียน
มีค่าไอเกนเป็นจำนวนจริงเท่านั้น แต่สามารถเป็นลบได้ แต่ถ้าเราเพิ่มข้อจำกัดว่าไม่มี
ค่าไอเกนใดเป็นลบ เราจะได้เมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอน และอีกอย่าง ถ้าให้
เมทริกซ์มาตัวหนึ่งแล้วอยากรู้ว่ามันเป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอนหรือเปล่า ก็สามารถตรวจสอบได้โดยใช้ลักษณะเฉพาะนี้ มันง่ายมากที่จะ
ตรวจว่าเมทริกซ์เป็นเอร์มิเชียนหรือเปล่า แค่ดูด้วยตาก็รู้ได้ การคำนวณค่าไอเกนยากกว่า
แต่ก็ไม่ยากเกินไปสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์ เพราะมีอัลกอริทึมที่มีประสิทธิภาพมากในการทำ
มัน และลักษณะเฉพาะสุดท้ายที่จะพูดถึง แม้ว่าจะมีอื่นๆ อีก คือสำหรับทุกเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ s ที่มี
จำนวนสมาชิกตรงกับจำนวนแถวและจำนวนคอลัมน์ของ rho อสมการที่แสดงบน
หน้าจอเป็นจริง พูดเป็นคำได้ว่า bra sai คูณ rho คูณ ket sai ต้องเป็นจำนวนจริงที่ไม่ติดลบ
อีกอย่าง มันไม่ชัดเจนว่าลักษณะเฉพาะเหล่านี้เทียบเท่ากัน แต่มันเทียบเท่ากัน และขอบอกชัดเจนว่า
สัญกรณ์ที่เราใช้กันทั่วไปเพื่อระบุว่าเมทริกซ์ rho เป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอน ดูเหมือน rho มากกว่า
หรือเท่ากับศูนย์ แต่นี่เป็นแค่สัญกรณ์ย่อ และไม่ได้หมายความว่า rho มากกว่า
หรือเท่ากับศูนย์จริงๆ rho เป็นเมทริกซ์ ดังนั้นมันไม่สมเหตุสมผล และไม่ได้หมายความ
ว่าสมาชิกแต่ละตัวของ rho มากกว่าหรือเท่ากับศูนย์ โดยเฉพาะ มีเมทริกซ์กึ่งบวก
แน่นอนที่สมาชิกไม่ได้ไม่ติดลบทั้งหมด และมีเมทริกซ์ที่สมาชิกไม่ติดลบทั้งหมด
แต่ไม่ได้เป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอน แนวคิดเบื้องหลังสัญกรณ์นี้คือเมทริกซ์กึ่งบวก
แน่นอนเหมือนตัวเปรียบเทียบในระดับเมทริกซ์ของจำนวนจริงที่ไม่ติดลบ แต่นี่เป็นแค่สัญกรณ์ และมันหมายถึง
สิ่งที่เราพูดไปแล้วอย่างแม่นยำ ตอนนี้มาดูตัวอย่างบางอย่างกัน เริ่มจากตัวอย่างของเมทริกซ์
กึ่งบวกแน่นอน จริงๆ แล้วมันง่ายมากที่จะสุ่มสร้างตัวอย่างของเมทริกซ์
กึ่งบวกแน่นอน แค่เลือกเมทริกซ์ M อะไรก็ได้แล้วคำนวณ M แด็กเกอร์คูณ
M ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือเมทริกซ์ M ที่ไม่ได้พิเศษอะไร และจริงๆ แล้ว
สุ่มสร้างเมทริกซ์นี้โดยเลือกส่วนจริงและส่วนจินตภาพของสมาชิกเป็นจำนวนเต็มระหว่างลบ 9 ถึงบวก
9 อย่างอิสระ ดังนั้นรูปแบบหรือโครงสร้างอะไรก็ตามในนี้เป็นเรื่องบังเอิญล้วนๆ โดยการคูณ
สังยุคทรานสโพสของ M กับ M เราได้เมทริกซ์นี้ ซึ่งจึงเป็นกึ่งบวก
แน่นอน แน่นอนว่ามีขีดจำกัดว่าเราจะได้ความเข้าใจลึกซึ้งแค่ไหนจากตัวอย่างสุ่ม แต่มันแสดง
ลักษณะบางอย่างที่พบได้ทั่วไปในเมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนโดยทั่วไป โดยเฉพาะจะสังเกตเห็นว่า
สมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุม ซึ่งก็คือตัวที่อยู่บนเส้นจากบนซ้ายไปล่างขวา เป็นจำนวนจริงที่ไม่ติดลบทั้งหมด
และยิ่งกว่านั้น สมาชิกนอกเส้นทแยงมุมมีขนาดไม่ใหญ่เกินไปเมื่อเทียบกับสมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุมที่สัมพันธ์กัน
หมายถึงตัวที่อยู่ในแถวเดียวกันและตัวที่อยู่ในคอลัมน์เดียวกันกับสมาชิกนอกเส้นทแยงมุมที่เรากำลังดู
อยู่ แต่มีเรื่องมากกว่านี้ และสำคัญที่ต้องรู้ว่าการเป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอนเป็น
คุณสมบัติของเมทริกซ์โดยรวม ไม่ใช่แค่เงื่อนไขของสมาชิกแต่ละตัว นั่นคือตัวอย่างของเมทริกซ์
กึ่งบวกแน่นอน และสามารถสร้างตัวอย่างอื่นได้ง่ายๆ ด้วยวิธีเดียวกัน
ตอนนี้มาดูตัวอย่างของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นกัน ที่นอกจากเงื่อนไขกึ่งบวกแน่นอนแล้ว เรายังมี trace เท่ากับ
หนึ่งด้วย นี่คือตัวอย่างบางอย่างของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นขนาด 2 คูณ 2 trace เท่ากับ
หนึ่งในทั้งสี่กรณี และเรายังเห็นว่าเหล่านี้เป็นเมทริกซ์เอร์มิเชียน ดังนั้นใช้ลักษณะเฉพาะที่สองของ
เมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนจากก่อนหน้านี้ ที่เหลือคือตรวจว่าค่าไอเกนทั้งหมดไม่ติดลบ
ลองตรวจเองถ้าต้องการ สำหรับเมทริกซ์ 2 คูณ 2 การคำนวณค่าไอเกนด้วยมือไม่ยากเกินไป
แต่ก็สามารถให้คอมพิวเตอร์ทำได้ ตัวอย่างเช่นใช้ฟังก์ชัน eigval ใน linear algebra package ของ Python เราสามารถได้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นโดยแค่เอา
เมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนที่ไม่ใช่ศูนย์ตัวใดก็ได้มาหารด้วย trace ของมัน ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่ได้จาก
การหารตัวอย่างที่เราเห็นเมื่อกี้ด้วย trace ของมัน การหารด้วย trace แบบนี้
จะรักษาคุณสมบัติกึ่งบวกแน่นอนเสมอ และเราจะได้เมทริกซ์ที่มี trace เท่ากับหนึ่งแน่นอน เนื่องจาก
trace เป็นฟังก์ชันเชิงเส้น นั่นเป็นแค่ตัวอย่างเล็กน้อย แล้วเราจะเห็นเพิ่มเมื่อ
บทเรียนดำเนินต่อไป ต่อไปเราจะใช้เวลาสักครู่พูดถึงการตีความหรือ
ความหมายเชิงสัญชาตญาณของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น สิ่งแรกที่ต้องยอมรับคือมันอาจดูแปลกนิดหน่อย
ที่เราแสดงสถานะของระบบด้วยเมทริกซ์แทนที่จะเป็นเวกเตอร์ ในทางตรงกันข้าม ในสูตร
แบบง่ายของข้อมูลควอนตัม เราใช้เวกเตอร์แสดงสถานะ ในขณะที่เมทริกซ์ โดยเฉพาะเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
แสดงการกระทำหรือการดำเนินการ นี่ก็แค่วิธีที่คณิตศาสตร์ทำงาน และแม้ว่า
จะคิดเกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์ในฐานะการอธิบายการส่งเชิงเส้นได้เสมอ เราไม่ค่อยเชื่อมโยงความหมายเชิงสัญชาตญาณ
โดยตรงกับการส่งเชิงเส้นที่สัมพันธ์กับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่กำหนดให้ อย่างไรก็ตาม ความจริงที่ว่า
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเป็นเมทริกซ์จริงๆ นั้นกลายเป็นด้านที่สำคัญมากของมัน แล้วเราจะเห็น
เมื่อเราดำเนินต่อไป แต่ขอพูดถึงสักตัวอย่างหนึ่งตอนนี้ ค่าไอเกนของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่กำหนดให้
กลายเป็นสิ่งสำคัญมากเพราะมันอธิบายว่ามีความสุ่มหรือความไม่แน่นอนมากแค่ไหนที่อยู่ในสถานะ
ที่เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นนั้นอธิบาย อีกวิธีในการคิดเกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นในระดับสัญชาตญาณ
เน้นที่สมาชิกของเมทริกซ์เหล่านี้ จำไว้ว่าแถวและคอลัมน์ของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นถูกจับคู่
กับสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบที่เรากำลังพูดถึง ดังนั้นสำหรับแต่ละสมาชิก เรามี
สถานะคลาสสิกหนึ่งที่ตรงกับแถวของสมาชิกนั้น และสถานะคลาสสิกหนึ่งที่ตรงกับคอลัมน์ของ
สมาชิกนั้น สำหรับสมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุม สถานะคลาสสิกทั้งสองเป็นสถานะเดียวกัน และนั่นคือเหตุผลที่สมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุม
พิเศษ และวิธีหนึ่งที่เราตีความสมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุมได้คือมันเป็นความน่าจะเป็น และโดยเฉพาะคือ
ความน่าจะเป็นที่สถานะคลาสสิกที่สอดคล้องกันจะปรากฏ ถ้าเราทำการวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐาน
บนระบบที่เรากำลังอธิบายสถานะควอนตัมอยู่ สำหรับสมาชิกนอกเส้นทแยงมุม เรามีสถานะคลาสสิกหนึ่งที่ตรงกับแถว
ของสมาชิกนั้น และสถานะคลาสสิกอีกตัวที่ต่างออกไปตรงกับคอลัมน์ของสมาชิกนั้น และพูดแบบไม่เป็นทางการ
สมาชิกเหล่านี้อธิบายระดับที่สถานะคลาสสิกสองตัวนี้อยู่ในการซ้อนทับควอนตัม รวมถึง
เฟสสัมพัทธ์ระหว่างมัน อาจเข้าใจมากขึ้นเมื่อบทเรียนดำเนินต่อไปและเราดู
ตัวอย่างเฉพาะอย่างใกล้ชิดขึ้น และรายละเอียดอาจยังไม่ชัดตอนนี้ แต่อย่าให้มัน
กังวล นี่ค่อนข้างไม่เป็นทางการ และแค่ตั้งใจให้เป็นไอเดียเชิงสัญชาตญาณที่เก็บไว้ในหัว
ต่อไปเราจะดูความเชื่อมโยงระหว่างเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นกับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม ซึ่งเป็นเวกเตอร์
คอลัมน์ที่มีนอร์มแบบยูคลิเดียนเท่ากับหนึ่ง แค่ทบทวนนิยามทางคณิตศาสตร์ สมมติว่าเรามี
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม psi ที่แสดงสถานะของระบบหนึ่ง เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่แสดงสถานะ
ควอนตัมเดียวกัน กำหนดโดย ket คูณ bra psi ดังที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ เพื่อให้ชัดเจน ดัชนีของ psi
สอดคล้องกับสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบที่เรากำลังพูดถึง และนั่นจะเป็นการจับคู่เดียวกันที่เรามีระหว่าง
แถวและคอลัมน์ของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นกับสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบ ถ้าเราจินตนาการว่ามี n
สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบ และเราคิดเกี่ยวกับเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์และแถวเป็นเมทริกซ์ ket จะเป็นเมทริกซ์ n คูณ 1
และ bra psi จะเป็นเมทริกซ์ 1 คูณ n ดังนั้นเมื่อเราคูณกัน เราจะได้เมทริกซ์ n คูณ n
นี่จะเป็นเมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนเสมอ จากรูปแบบของมันเอง และมันจะมี trace เท่ากับ
หนึ่งด้วย เนื่องจาก psi เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย และเราจะเห็นรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติม
ในอีกสักครู่ สถานะควอนตัมที่แสดงด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นในรูปแบบนี้เรียกว่าสถานะ
บริสุทธิ์ นี่คือตัวอย่างบางส่วน ก่อนอื่นมาพิจารณาสถานะ
นี้ ซึ่งคล้ายสถานะ plus ยกเว้นว่าสมาชิกที่ตรงกับสถานะคลาสสิก 1 เป็น
จำนวนจินตภาพ ถ้าเราคำนวณสังยุคทรานสโพส เราจะติดเครื่องหมายลบเพราะสังยุคเชิงซ้อนของ i คือ
ลบ i และถ้าเราคูณกัน เราจะได้เมทริกซ์ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ มันเป็นเอร์มิเชียนอย่างที่เห็น
ได้ทันทีแค่ดู และมันมีค่าไอเกนหนึ่งเท่ากับหนึ่งและค่าไอเกนหนึ่งเท่ากับ
ศูนย์ ดังนั้นมันเป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอนและ trace เท่ากับหนึ่ง จึงเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
อย่างที่คาดไว้ เราสามารถคำนวณเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่สอดคล้องกับฐานมาตรฐานและฐาน plus minus ในทำนองเดียวกัน และเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเหล่านั้น
แสดงที่นี่ และนี่อีกตัวอย่างหนึ่งของเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม มันเคยปรากฏ
ในบทเรียนแรกของซีรีส์ และถ้าเราคำนวณสังยุคทรานสโพสแล้วคูณ
เราจะได้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่แสดงที่นี่ อีกครั้งมันเป็นเอร์มิเชียนและมี
trace เท่ากับหนึ่ง และถ้าคำนวณค่าไอเกน จะพบว่ามันมีค่าไอเกนหนึ่งเท่ากับหนึ่งและหนึ่ง
เท่ากับศูนย์อีกครั้ง และอีกอย่าง นั่นเป็นลักษณะร่วมของสถานะบริสุทธิ์ทุกตัว มันมีค่าไอเกนหนึ่งเท่ากับหนึ่ง
เสมอ และค่าไอเกนที่เหลือเป็นศูนย์ทั้งหมด โดยทั่วไปสำหรับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
psi ที่ไม่จำกัดรูปแบบ มีจำนวนสมาชิกกี่ตัวก็ได้ ถ้าเราคูณ ket กับ bra psi เราจะได้
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่หน้าตาแบบนี้ สังเกตโดยเฉพาะว่าสมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุมเป็น
สมาชิกตัวหนึ่งของ psi คูณกับสังยุคเชิงซ้อนของตัวมันเอง ซึ่งเราสามารถเขียนเป็นค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองของสมาชิกนั้นได้ และนี่คือ
วิธีหนึ่งที่เห็นว่า trace จะเท่ากับหนึ่งเสมอ มันยังสอดคล้องกับข้อสังเกตที่บอกไว้ก่อนหน้านี้ว่า
สมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุมของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นบอกเราว่าความน่าจะเป็นจะเป็นเท่าไหร่ที่จะเห็นแต่ละสถานะคลาสสิก
ถ้าเราทำการวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐาน และข้อสังเกตสุดท้าย
ไม่มีปัญหาเรื่องเฟสรวมสำหรับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น สถานะควอนตัมสองตัวเหมือนกันก็ต่อเมื่อเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
ของมันเท่ากัน โดยเฉพาะ สมมติว่าเรามีเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมสองตัว psi และ phi ที่
เทียบเท่ากันจนถึงเฟสรวม ซึ่งหมายความว่าเราสามารถเขียนตัวหนึ่ง phi สมมติ เป็นอีกตัวคูณ
จำนวนเชิงซ้อนบนวงกลมหนึ่งหน่วย ถ้าเราคำนวณการแสดงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของ phi สิ่งที่เราจะ
พบคือตัวคูณเฟสรวมถูกคูณด้วยสังยุคเชิงซ้อนของตัวมันเอง ซึ่งให้เราได้หนึ่ง ดังนั้นมัน
หายไปอย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ และเราเหลือเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นตัวเดียวกันทุกประการที่ได้จาก psi นั่นเป็น
โบนัสเล็กๆ น้อยๆ ที่ดี และโดยทั่วไปแล้วไม่มีปัญหาเรื่องความเทียบเท่าจนถึงเฟสรวมเลยเมื่อเรา
ทำงานกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น นั่นก็แค่ความเสื่อมที่มีอยู่เมื่อเราใช้เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
แทนที่จะใช้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแสดงสถานะควอนตัม เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นมีคุณสมบัติสำคัญคือการรวมแบบนูน
ของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแสดงการเลือกแบบความน่าจะเป็นหรือแบบสุ่มของสถานะ
ควอนตัม พูดอีกอย่างคือเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นสามารถถูกเฉลี่ยเข้าด้วยกันอย่างมีความหมาย ซึ่งเป็น
สิ่งที่ทำไม่ได้กับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม เพื่ออธิบายรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติม มาเริ่มจากสถานการณ์ที่
เรามีเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นสองตัว rho และ sigma ที่แสดงสถานะควอนตัมของระบบหนึ่ง ลองจินตนาการว่า
ระบบถูกเตรียมในสถานะ rho ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น p สำหรับค่า p ที่อยู่ระหว่างศูนย์ถึงหนึ่ง และไม่เช่นนั้น
ระบบถูกเตรียมในสถานะ sigma ตัวอย่างเช่น บางที p คือ 1/2 ดังนั้นเรา
อาจจินตนาการว่ามีคนโยนเหรียญที่ยุติธรรม และถ้าออกหัวก็ทำกระบวนการที่ทำให้ระบบอยู่ใน
สถานะ rho และไม่เช่นนั้นถ้าเหรียญออกก้อยก็ทำกระบวนการอื่นที่ทำให้ระบบอยู่ใน
สถานะ sigma คำถามตอนนี้คือสถานะของระบบคืออะไร และให้ชัดเจน
เราสนใจสถานะของระบบโดยลำพัง ไม่สนใจข้อมูลอื่นที่อาจมีอยู่เกี่ยวกับ
การเตรียมที่ถูกทำ ตัวอย่างเช่น จินตนาการว่าเราไม่มีการเข้าถึงเหรียญหรือ
ความทรงจำของคนที่ทำการเตรียมสถานะ และคำตอบของคำถามนั้นคือมันก็แค่ค่าเฉลี่ยถ่วงน้ำหนักของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นสองตัว
p คูณ rho บวก 1 ลบ p คูณ sigma นี่เป็นเรื่อง
ที่คล้ายคลึงกับสิ่งที่จะเกิดขึ้นถ้า rho และ sigma ไม่ใช่เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น แต่เป็นเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น
ที่แสดงสถานะความน่าจะเป็น ดังนั้นนี่ไม่ใช่เรื่องน่าตกใจหรือลึกลับ แต่เป็นสิ่งที่
อาจคุ้นเคยจากทฤษฎีความน่าจะเป็น เราทำการเฉลี่ยแบบนี้ตลอดเวลาเมื่อเราคำนวณความน่าจะเป็นและคิด
เกี่ยวกับการสุ่มเลือกแบบคลาสสิก และประเด็นคือนี่ใช้ได้กับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นด้วย แต่สังเกตว่ามัน
ใช้ไม่ได้กับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม คือเฉลี่ยเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมสองตัว
เข้าด้วยกันแบบนี้ไม่ได้ทั่วไป แล้วหวังว่าจะได้เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมที่ถูกต้อง และถ้าลอง ก็จะมักได้เวกเตอร์ที่
ไม่มีนอร์มแบบยูคลิเดียนเท่ากับหนึ่ง แต่กับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น ค่าเฉลี่ยถ่วงน้ำหนักแบบนี้จะ
เป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่ถูกต้องเสมอ และที่สำคัญกว่านั้น เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่ได้จะแสดงการสุ่มเลือกนั้น
อย่างมีความหมาย นี่ขยายไปถึงการสุ่มเลือกที่มีมากกว่าสอง
ทางเลือก โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเรามีเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่เป็นไปได้ m ตัว และเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นที่มี m สมาชิก หนึ่ง
ตัวสำหรับแต่ละเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น และระบบถูกเตรียมในแต่ละสถานะที่เป็นไปได้ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นที่สอดคล้องกัน
ค่าเฉลี่ยถ่วงน้ำหนักของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเหล่านั้นจะอธิบายสถานะที่ได้ของระบบ และอีกอย่างเมื่อ
เราพูดถึงการรวมแบบนูนของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น นี่คือสิ่งที่เราหมายถึง การรวมแบบนูนก็แค่การรวมเชิงเส้น
ที่สัมประสิทธิ์เป็นเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น นี่จะเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเสมอ
และวิธีพูดที่เรียบง่ายและกระชับในทางคณิตศาสตร์คือเซตของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นทั้งหมด
ที่สอดคล้องกับระบบที่กำหนดเป็นเซตนูน ดังนั้นถ้าเรามีเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
psi 0 ถึง psi m ลบหนึ่ง พร้อมกับความน่าจะเป็น p 0 ถึง p m ลบหนึ่ง ที่รวมกันเป็น
เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น และระบบถูกเตรียมในสถานะ psi k ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น p k สำหรับแต่ละ k สถานะ
ที่ได้ของระบบอธิบายด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ โดยเฉพาะเราไม่ได้เฉลี่ย
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมเข้าด้วยกัน แต่เราเฉลี่ยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่สอดคล้องกัน
เข้าด้วยกัน โดยทั่วไปสถานะแบบนี้จะไม่มีการแสดงเป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมตัวเดียว
ยกเว้นมีอะไรเกิดขึ้นแบบเล็กน้อย เช่น เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมทั้งหมดเทียบเท่ากันจนถึงเฟสรวม หรือมีแค่ตัวเดียวที่
ความน่าจะเป็นไม่เป็นศูนย์ เราจะไม่ได้สถานะควอนตัมบริสุทธิ์จากกระบวนการแบบนี้ แต่จะได้สิ่งที่
เรียกว่าสถานะควอนตัมผสม ที่มีความไม่แน่นอนโดยธรรมชาติอยู่ มาดูตัวอย่าง
ง่ายๆ สมมติว่าเรามี qubit และด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 qubit ถูกเตรียมในสถานะศูนย์ และไม่เช่นนั้น
มันถูกเตรียมในสถานะ plus นี่คือเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่ได้จากการเฉลี่ยอย่างที่
อธิบายไว้ เราคำนวณเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่สอดคล้องกับสองสถานะที่เป็นไปได้ คูณด้วยความน่าจะเป็นที่สอดคล้องกัน แล้วบวก
ผลลัพธ์ สิ่งที่ได้คือเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นจริงๆ มันเป็นเอร์มิเชียน trace เท่ากับหนึ่ง
และถ้าคำนวณค่าไอเกนของเมทริกซ์นี้ จะได้จำนวนจริงบวกสองตัว และบังเอิญเป็นตัวเลขที่น่าจะคุ้นเคย
แล้ว cosine กำลังสองของ pi หาร 8 และ sine กำลังสองของ pi หาร 8 หรือประมาณ 0.85 กับ
0.15 ไม่มีการแสดงเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมตัวเดียวของสถานะนี้ มันไม่ใช่สถานะบริสุทธิ์ ต่อไปมาดู
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นตัวหนึ่งที่แสดงสถานะควอนตัมของ qubit เดี่ยวที่เรียกว่าสถานะผสม
สมบูรณ์ สถานะนี้เกิดขึ้นบ่อย จึงดีที่มีชื่อให้มัน และมันยังเป็นตัวอย่างที่ดีเพราะ
มันแสดงคุณสมบัติสำคัญของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น จริงๆ แล้วมีสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ที่นิยามในแบบเดียวกันสำหรับ
ระบบใดก็ได้ แต่ตอนนี้เราจะเน้นที่สถานะนี้สำหรับ qubit เดี่ยวเพื่อให้ง่าย
สมมติว่าเราตั้งสถานะของ qubit แบบสุ่มให้เป็นสถานะศูนย์หรือสถานะหนึ่ง แต่ละตัวด้วย
ความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 เหมือนบิตสุ่มแบบสม่ำเสมอ เราสามารถคำนวณเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของสถานะนี้
ตามวิธีปกติ เอาค่าเฉลี่ยของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของทั้งสองสถานะ นี่คือ
หน้าตาในรูปแบบเมทริกซ์ และสิ่งที่ได้คือเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์หารด้วย
สอง สถานะนี้เรียกว่าสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ และมันแสดงความไม่แน่นอนที่สมบูรณ์หรือสูงสุด
เกี่ยวกับ qubit เหมือนกับที่เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นแบบสม่ำเสมอแสดงความไม่แน่นอนสูงสุดใน
บริบทความน่าจะเป็นแบบคลาสสิก โดยทั่วไปสำหรับระบบใดก็ได้ สถานะผสมสมบูรณ์คือ
สถานะที่ได้จากการเลือกสถานะฐานมาตรฐานแบบสม่ำเสมอ และเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นจะเป็น
เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์หารด้วยมิติ หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือจำนวนสถานะคลาสสิกของ
ระบบนั้น ตอนนี้นี่เป็นแค่ศัพท์ แต่ถ้าเราเปลี่ยนการตั้งค่านิดหน่อย เราจะเห็นคุณสมบัติสำคัญของ
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น โดยเฉพาะ สมมติว่าเราเปลี่ยนขั้นตอนและ
แทนที่สถานะฐานมาตรฐานศูนย์และหนึ่ง ด้วยสถานะ plus และ minus คราวนี้เราเริ่มจาก
นิพจน์ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ แต่ถ้าเราทำเลขคณิต เราจะได้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
ตัวเดียวกันทุกประการ มันคือเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์หารด้วยสอง เป็นสถานะเดียวกันกับก่อนหน้านี้ คือ
สถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ อย่างที่เขาว่ากัน นี่เป็นฟีเจอร์ไม่ใช่บัก ทั้งสองขั้นตอนต่าง
กันจริง แต่ถ้ามีแค่ qubit ที่ได้ ไม่มีทางทางกายภาพที่จะแยกแยะมันได้
แม้ในเชิงสถิติ ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าทำการวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐานบน qubit นี้
หลังจากทำขั้นตอนแรก ก็จะได้ผลลัพธ์ศูนย์ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 และผลลัพธ์หนึ่งด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 อย่างชัดเจน แต่ก็จะได้
ความน่าจะเป็นของผลลัพธ์เหมือนกันทุกประการสำหรับขั้นตอนที่สอง และเช่นเดียวกันสำหรับการทดสอบอื่นใดที่อาจ
คิดขึ้นมา สมมติว่าทดสอบแค่ qubit ตัวนั้นเอง โดยทั่วไป เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นไม่ได้อธิบายว่าระบบถูก
เตรียมมายังไง มันแค่บอกว่าจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้าทำอะไรกับระบบนั้นต่อไป ไม่ว่าจะเป็นการทำ
การดำเนินการหรือการวัด และจริงๆ แล้วเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นสมบูรณ์แบบในเรื่องนี้
ถ้าสองทางเลือกที่ต่างกันให้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเดียวกัน มันไม่สามารถแยกแยะได้แม้
ในเชิงสถิติ แต่ถ้าเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นสองตัวต่างกัน ก็จะมีทางแยกแยะมันได้ ไม่
จำเป็นต้องอย่างเด็ดขาด แต่ในเชิงสถิติ เมื่อเราใช้สูตรทั่วไปของข้อมูล
ควอนตัม ข้อมูลคลาสสิกจะกลายเป็นกรณีพิเศษ และจะอธิบายว่ามัน
ทำงานยังไง โดยเฉพาะเราจะเห็นว่าสถานะความน่าจะเป็นสามารถแสดงด้วยเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่นได้ยังไง มาเริ่มจากสถานะคลาสสิกกัน ด้วยตัวอย่าง
ง่ายๆ นี่คือเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่แสดงสถานะฐานมาตรฐานศูนย์และหนึ่งของ
qubit เราเชื่อมโยงสถานะเหล่านี้กับสถานะคลาสสิก 0 และ 1 ดังนั้นเราสามารถคิดว่าเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเหล่านี้
แสดงสถานะเหล่านั้น ง่ายมาก และเราสามารถขยายตัวอย่าง
ได้ง่ายๆ ถ้าเรามีระบบที่เซตสถานะคลาสสิกคือ Sigma สถานะคลาสสิก a แสดงด้วยหรือ
สัมพันธ์กับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น ket a bra a เมทริกซ์นั้นมีเลขหนึ่งตัวเดียวใน
สมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุมที่แถวและคอลัมน์สอดคล้องกับสถานะคลาสสิก a และสมาชิกอื่นทุกตัวเป็น
ศูนย์ สถานะความน่าจะเป็นแสดงด้วยการรวมแบบนูนของเมทริกซ์ในรูปแบบนี้ ซึ่งเป็นธรรมชาติ
จากสิ่งที่เรารู้เกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นและการทำงานของมัน โดยเฉพาะว่าการรวมแบบนูนของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแสดงการเลือกแบบสุ่มหรือ
ความน่าจะเป็นของสถานะควอนตัม ตัวอย่างเช่น สมมติว่า
เรามีระบบ X ที่เซตสถานะคลาสสิกรวมจำนวนเต็ม 0 ถึง n ลบหนึ่ง สำหรับจำนวนเต็มบวก n ที่
แน่นอนว่าไม่สูญเสียความทั่วไปมากในการสมมติว่าเซตสถานะคลาสสิกมีรูปแบบนี้ ถ้ามี
เซตสถานะคลาสสิกอื่น เราแค่เปลี่ยนชื่อสถานะคลาสสิกแบบนี้ได้ และมักจะสะดวกที่จะสมมติว่า
เซตสถานะคลาสสิกมีหน้าตาแบบนี้ ส่วนใหญ่เพราะมันทำให้เขียนสิ่งต่างๆ อย่างชัดเจนในรูปของ
เวกเตอร์และเมทริกซ์ได้ง่ายขึ้น สมมติว่าเรามีสถานะความน่าจะเป็นของระบบ X
แสดงด้วยเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นตามปกติ เราสามารถเชื่อมโยงสถานะความน่าจะเป็นนี้กับเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่นดังที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ เราเอาค่าเฉลี่ยถ่วงน้ำหนักของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่สอดคล้องกับ
สถานะคลาสสิกต่างๆ และสิ่งที่ได้คือเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแนวทแยง โดยเฉพาะเราเห็นความน่าจะเป็น
ตามแนวทแยงมุมของเมทริกซ์นี้ และสมาชิกอื่นทุกตัวเท่ากับศูนย์ แน่นอนว่านี่เป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
เราคาดว่าจะเป็นอย่างนั้น แต่ก็สามารถเหตุผลได้โดยตรง มันเป็นเมทริกซ์เอร์มิเชียน trace
เท่ากับหนึ่งเพราะความน่าจะเป็นรวมกันเป็นหนึ่ง และในกรณีของเมทริกซ์แนวทแยง ค่าไอเกนคือสมาชิกบนเส้นทแยงมุม
และมันไม่ติดลบทั้งหมดเพราะมันเป็นความน่าจะเป็น สังเกตด้วยว่า
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแนวทแยงทุกตัว คือตัวที่สมาชิกนอกเส้นทแยงมุมเป็นศูนย์ทั้งหมด ต้องมีหน้าตาแบบนี้ สรุปสั้นๆ
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นสามารถเชื่อมโยงกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแนวทแยงได้ สังเกตอีกอย่างว่านี่สอดคล้องกับ
การตีความแบบไม่เป็นทางการของสมาชิกของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่พูดถึงตอนต้นบทเรียน โดยเฉพาะไม่มีอะไรอยู่ใน
การซ้อนทับควอนตัมที่นี่ มันเป็นแค่ความสุ่มแบบคลาสสิก และตามนั้นสมาชิกนอกเส้นทแยงมุมทั้งหมด
เป็นศูนย์ ก่อนหน้านี้ในซีรีส์ เราพูดถึงทฤษฎีบทสเปกตรัล และเราทำ
โดยเฉพาะสำหรับเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี ในบริบทของการประมาณค่าเฟส ทฤษฎีบทสเปกตรัลเป็น
เรื่องทั่วไปกว่านั้น หมายความว่ามันบอกเราบางอย่างเกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์ที่กว้างกว่าแค่เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
และโดยเฉพาะมันใช้ได้กับเมทริกซ์ประเภทหนึ่งที่เรียกว่าเมทริกซ์ปกติ ซึ่งรวมเมทริกซ์ทุกตัวรวมถึง
เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี สิ่งที่เราจะทำตอนนี้คือดูข้อความอีกแบบของทฤษฎีบทนี้ คราวนี้เน้นที่แค่
เมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอน แล้วเราจะเห็นว่ามันบอกเราเรื่องที่น่าสนใจและสำคัญมากเกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่น สมมติว่า P เป็นเมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนใดก็ได้ รวมถึงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นทุกตัว รวมถึง
เมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนที่บังเอิญไม่มี trace เท่ากับหนึ่ง P เป็นกึ่งบวกแน่นอน ดังนั้นต้อง
เป็นจัตุรัส หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ n คูณ n สำหรับค่า n ที่เลือก และเราจะต้องอ้างถึงจำนวน n ดังนั้นให้ n เป็น
ค่าที่เหมาะสม หรืออีกวิธีหนึ่งคือสมมติว่า P เป็น n คูณ n สิ่งที่ทฤษฎีบทบอกเราในกรณีนี้คือ
ต้องมีฐานเชิงตั้งฉากปกติของเวกเตอร์ ซึ่งเราจะเรียกว่า psi 0 ถึง psi n ลบหนึ่ง พร้อมกับจำนวนจริงที่ไม่ติดลบ
Lambda 0 ถึง Lambda n ลบหนึ่ง ที่ P สามารถแสดงได้ดังที่แสดง
บนหน้าจอ พูดเป็นคำได้ว่า ถ้าเราคูณ Lambda k แต่ละตัวกับ ket psi k คูณ bra psi k แล้ว
รวมทั้งหมดจาก k เท่ากับ 0 ถึง n ลบหนึ่ง เราจะได้ P นี่เรียกว่าการแยกสเปกตรัล
ของ P แต่ละ Lambda k จำเป็นต้องเป็นค่าไอเกนของ P และแต่ละ psi เป็นเวกเตอร์ไอเกนหนึ่งหน่วยของ P
ที่สอดคล้องกับค่าไอเกนนั้น ถ้าดูย้อนกลับไปที่บทเรียน 7 เรื่องการประมาณค่าเฟส จะพบทฤษฎีบทที่คล้ายกัน
สำหรับเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี ตรงนั้นค่าไอเกนเป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อนบนวงกลมหนึ่งหน่วย แทนที่จะเป็นจำนวนจริงที่ไม่ติดลบ
แต่นอกจากนั้นมันเป็นไอเดียเดียวกัน และจริงๆ แล้วทั้งสองเป็นกรณีพิเศษของทฤษฎีบทที่ทั่วไปกว่าที่เรียกว่า
ทฤษฎีบทสเปกตรัล มันไม่ทำงานกับทุกเมทริกซ์ เมทริกซ์ต้องสลับที่ได้กับ
สังยุคทรานสโพสของมันเอง และนั่นคือความหมายของเมทริกซ์ปกติ แต่จริงๆ แล้วเรา
มีคุณสมบัตินี้เสมอสำหรับทั้งเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีและเมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอน และสำหรับเมทริกซ์เอร์มิเชียนโดยทั่วไป ที่
จะมีค่าไอเกนเป็นจำนวนจริงเสมอ แต่ไม่จำเป็นต้องไม่ติดลบ นั่นคือข้อความของ
ทฤษฎีบทสเปกตรัลสำหรับเมทริกซ์กึ่งบวกแน่นอนเท่านั้น และตอนนี้มาดูว่ามันบอกอะไรเราเกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่น สิ่งที่มันบอกคือสำหรับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น n คูณ n ใดก็ได้ เราสามารถแสดงเมทริกซ์นั้นเป็นการรวมแบบนูน
ของสถานะบริสุทธิ์ n ตัว และยิ่งกว่านั้นเราสามารถให้สถานะบริสุทธิ์ n ตัวนั้นเป็น
ฐานเชิงตั้งฉากได้ นี่ตามมาค่อนข้างตรงจากทฤษฎีบทร่วมกับข้อเท็จจริงพื้นฐานจากพีชคณิตเชิงเส้น คือ
ผลรวมของค่าไอเกนของเมทริกซ์ใดก็ได้เท่ากับ trace ของเมทริกซ์นั้นเสมอ พูดอีกอย่างคือสิ่งที่เราทำ
ก็แค่เปลี่ยนชื่อค่าไอเกนเป็น p 0 ถึง p n ลบหนึ่ง แล้วสังเกตว่าเมื่อเราทำแบบนั้นและ
รวมค่าไอเกนเหล่านั้นเป็นเวกเตอร์ n มิติ เราจะได้เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นเสมอ เพราะมันต้องไม่ติดลบทั้งหมดและผลรวมเท่ากับ
trace ของ rho ซึ่งเท่ากับหนึ่ง เพราะ rho เป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น นั่นค่อนข้างง่าย แต่
จริงๆ แล้วมันเป็นเรื่องพื้นฐานมากในเชิงแนวคิด สิ่งที่มันบอกเราคือทุกเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น ไม่ว่า
จะดูซับซ้อนแค่ไหน อาจเกิดขึ้นจากการเลือกฐานเชิงตั้งฉากปกติของระบบ
ที่เรากำลังพูดถึงก่อน แล้วสุ่มเลือกสถานะควอนตัมจากฐานนั้นตามความน่าจะเป็นที่เลือก
ไว้ ถ้ายังไม่เห็นทันทีว่าทำไมมันน่าสนใจหรือสำคัญ ก็ไม่เป็นไร แต่เราใช้ข้อเท็จจริง
นี้บ่อยมากเมื่อเราให้เหตุผลเกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น และจริงๆ แล้วการแสดงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่กำหนดให้
ในรูปแบบนี้มักจะเป็นสิ่งแรกที่เราทำเมื่อต้องการเข้าใจมัน
ให้ดีขึ้น นี่คือตัวอย่าง จำเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่เราได้มาก่อนหน้านี้ ที่เราสุ่มเลือกระหว่าง
สถานะศูนย์กับสถานะ plus แต่ละตัวด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 ซึ่งอย่างที่เราคำนวณไว้ มีเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่
หน้าตาแบบนี้ สถานะศูนย์และสถานะ plus ไม่ตั้งฉากกัน ดังนั้นนี่ไม่ใช่
การแยกสเปกตรัล แต่ถ้าเราคำนวณมัน ซึ่งทำได้ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์หรือด้วยมือในกรณีแบบนี้ สิ่งที่
ได้คือนิพจน์ของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นนี้ ที่ค่าไอเกนเป็นตัวเลขที่โผล่มาเรื่อย และ
เวกเตอร์ไอเกนที่สอดคล้องกันสามารถเลือกได้ดังที่แสดงด้านล่างบนหน้าจอ และอีกครั้ง เราเคยเห็นเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้มาก่อน เช่นใน
บริบทของเกม CHSH ในบทเรียนที่สี่ น่าสนใจ ตาม
นิพจน์เดิม สถานะนี้คือสิ่งที่ได้จากการเลือกแบบสม่ำเสมอระหว่างสองสถานะ คือสถานะศูนย์กับ
สถานะ plus แต่จริงๆ แล้วเราได้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเดียวกันจากการสุ่มเลือกระหว่างสถานะบริสุทธิ์สองตัว
แต่เราถ่วงน้ำหนักไปทางตัวหนึ่งมากๆ ประมาณ 85% สำหรับตัวแรก และแค่ประมาณ 15% สำหรับ
ตัวที่สอง ดังนั้นในแง่หนึ่ง จริงๆ แล้วมีความสุ่มน้อยกว่าที่ดูเหมือนตอนแรก
มีวิธีทางเรขาคณิตที่ดีมากในการคิดและแสดงภาพสถานะควอนตัมของ qubit เดี่ยว ที่เรียกว่า
Block sphere มันใช้ได้กับ qubit เดี่ยวเท่านั้น สำหรับระบบที่มีสาม
หรือมากกว่าสถานะคลาสสิก รวมถึง qubit สองตัวขึ้นไปรวมกัน มันใช้ไม่ได้อีกต่อไป ดังนั้นมันค่อนข้างจำกัด แต่
ก็ยังเป็นวิธีที่ดีมากในการคิดเกี่ยวกับสถานะของ qubit เดี่ยว มันอาจถูกแนะนำ
ตั้งแต่บทเรียนแรกของซีรีส์เรื่องระบบเดี่ยว แต่มันไม่จำเป็นจริงๆ สำหรับการเข้าใจว่าข้อมูลควอนตัมทำงานยังไง และมันยังมี
ความเชื่อมโยงที่ดีกับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น จึงเข้ากับบทเรียนนี้อย่างเป็นธรรมชาติ และจริงๆ แล้วจะอธิบาย
มันในวิธีที่อาจต่างจากที่มักอธิบายกัน โดยใช้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเพื่อ
derive มันอย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ ดังนั้นถ้าคุ้นเคยกับ Block sphere อยู่แล้ว คำอธิบายนี้อาจต่างจาก
วิธีที่เรียนรู้ครั้งแรก แต่สุดท้ายมันควรจะเทียบเท่ากัน เราจะเริ่มจากการคิดเกี่ยวกับ
สถานะบริสุทธิ์ที่เป็นไปได้ของ qubit ก่อน ดังที่แสดงด้วยเวกเตอร์สถานะ
ควอนตัม จนถึงเฟสรวม เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมของ qubit ทุกตัวสามารถแสดงได้
ดังที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ พูดให้แม่นยำ เรามีจำนวนจริงสองตัว theta และ phi แล้วเราจะคิดเกี่ยวกับ
สองจำนวนนี้ในฐานะมุมที่แสดงเป็นเรเดียน จำนวนแรก theta อยู่ระหว่าง 0 ถึง pi หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ
มุมระหว่าง 0 ถึง 180 องศา และจำนวนที่สอง phi อยู่ระหว่าง 0 ถึง 2 pi รวม 0 แต่ไม่รวม 2
pi ดังนั้นมุมใดก็ได้ระหว่าง 0 ถึง 360 องศา สมาชิกที่ศูนย์ของเวกเตอร์คือ
cosine ของ theta หาร 2 ดังนั้นมันเป็นจำนวนจริงระหว่าง 0 ถึง 1 และโดยเฉพาะมันไม่ติดลบเสมอ
และสมาชิกที่หนึ่งของเวกเตอร์คือ e ยกกำลัง i คูณ phi คูณ sine ของ theta หาร 2 และนั่นสามารถ
เป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อนใดก็ได้บนหรือภายในวงกลมหนึ่งหน่วยเชิงซ้อน นี่เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยเสมอ หรือ
พูดอีกอย่างคือมันเป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมที่ถูกต้อง และสำหรับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมของ qubit ใดก็ได้ เราสามารถหา
เวกเตอร์ในรูปแบบนี้ที่เทียบเท่ากับเวกเตอร์นั้นจนถึงเฟสรวมได้เสมอ โดยเฉพาะเราสามารถ
คูณเวกเตอร์ที่ให้มาด้วยเฟสรวมเพื่อให้สมาชิกที่ศูนย์เป็นจำนวนจริงที่ไม่ติดลบ เลือก
theta ที่ให้สมาชิกนั้น แล้วเลือก phi ให้ตรงกับสมาชิกที่หนึ่ง ขนาดของสมาชิกที่หนึ่งจะ
ตรงกับ sine ของ theta หาร 2 เสมอ จากสมมติฐานที่ว่าเราเริ่มจากเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย
ตอนนี้ มันไม่ใช่ว่า theta และ phi จะถูกกำหนดอย่างเดียวจากเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมที่เราเริ่มต้น
แต่เกือบจะเป็นเช่นนั้น จะมีค่า theta ระหว่างศูนย์ถึง pi ที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์เสมอ
และปกติจะมีค่า phi ที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์ที่ใช้ได้ แต่ในสองกรณีพิเศษมันไม่จริง โดยเฉพาะถ้าเราเริ่มจาก
สถานะฐานมาตรฐาน theta จะเป็นศูนย์หรือ pi และในทั้งสองกรณี มันไม่สำคัญว่า phi จะเป็นอะไร มัน
ไม่เกี่ยวเลย เมื่อ theta เป็นศูนย์ cosine ของ theta หาร 2 เป็น 1 และ sine ของ theta หาร 2
เป็นศูนย์ ดังนั้นเราคูณ e ยกกำลัง i คูณ phi กับศูนย์ ดังนั้นไม่ว่า phi จะเป็นอะไรก็ไม่ต่าง
และถ้า theta เป็น pi คราวนี้ cosine เป็นศูนย์ และ sine เป็นหนึ่ง ดังนั้นเราได้ e ยกกำลัง i คูณ phi คูณ ket 1 แต่เวกเตอร์
เหล่านั้นเทียบเท่ากันจนถึงเฟสรวมทั้งหมด ดังนั้นอีกครั้ง phi จะเป็นอะไรก็ไม่สำคัญ แต่ถ้า theta อยู่
ระหว่างศูนย์กับ pi อย่างแท้จริง จะมีค่า phi ที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์เสมอที่ใช้ได้ และอีกอย่าง ความเสื่อม
ที่อาจเกิดขึ้นของค่า phi สำหรับสองกรณีพิเศษจะสมเหตุสมผลเมื่อเราเห็นภาพทางเรขาคณิตใน
อีกสักครู่ ตอนนี้มาคำนวณเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่สัมพันธ์กับเวกเตอร์สถานะในรูปแบบที่เราเพิ่ง
ระบุ ดังนั้นนี่จะเป็นสถานะบริสุทธิ์ของ qubit เพื่อทำสิ่งนี้เราคูณเวกเตอร์
กับสังยุคทรานสโพสตามปกติ และบนหน้าจอคือนิพจน์ของเมทริกซ์ที่ได้จากการคำนวณ
สังยุคทรานสโพสและทำการคูณ เหมือนกับเมทริกซ์ 2 คูณ 2 ทุกตัว
มีวิธีเดียวที่จะได้เมทริกซ์นี้โดยเอาการรวมเชิงเส้นของเมทริกซ์ Pauli
รวมถึงเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ โดยเฉพาะเราสามารถได้เมทริกซ์นี้โดยเลือกสัมประสิทธิ์ของ
เมทริกซ์ Pauli ดังที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ เราใส่สองในตัวหารเพราะมันจะทำให้
ทุกอย่างออกมาสวย ไม่มีอะไรบังคับให้ทำแบบนี้ แต่เราทำได้ และมันจะมีประโยชน์ แต่นอกจาก
ตัวเลือกด้านรูปแบบนี้ ไม่มีอิสระอื่น นี่เป็นวิธีเดียวที่จะได้เมทริกซ์นี้จากการรวมเชิงเส้นของเมทริกซ์ Pauli นั่น
เป็นเพราะเมทริกซ์ Pauli รวมถึงเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์เป็นฐานของปริภูมิเวกเตอร์ของเมทริกซ์ 2 คูณ 2 ทั้งหมด วิธีหนึ่ง
ในการตรวจความถูกต้องของนิพจน์นี้คือใช้เอกลักษณ์ตรีโกณมิติพื้นฐาน และโดยเฉพาะถ้าหลบออกไปสักครู่
ตรงนี้ นี่คือเอกลักษณ์บางตัวที่จะช่วยได้ ดังนั้นถ้าต้องการ หยุดวิดีโอหรือ
ถ่ายภาพหน้าจอ แล้วลองดูว่าสามารถได้นิพจน์ที่สองของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นด้านล่างจากตัวแรกได้ไหม สรุปแล้ว สถานะบริสุทธิ์ของ
qubit ทุกตัวที่แสดงเป็นเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นสามารถเขียนเป็นการรวมเชิงเส้นของเมทริกซ์ Pauli ได้ดังที่แสดงบน
หน้าจอ สำหรับ theta ระหว่าง 0 ถึง pi และ phi ระหว่าง 0 ถึง 2 pi สังเกตว่าเรามี
ความเสื่อมเดียวกันกับก่อนหน้านี้ คือ phi ไม่เกี่ยวเมื่อ theta เป็นศูนย์หรือ pi และคราวนี้เราเห็น
ได้ชัดขึ้น เพราะ sine ของ theta เป็นศูนย์ในสองกรณีนั้น และกรณีอื่นไม่เป็น ควรชี้ให้เห็น
ว่าในสูตรนี้ เรามี theta เป็นอาร์กิวเมนต์ของฟังก์ชัน sine และ cosine แทนที่จะเป็น theta หาร 2 เหมือนในเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
ตัวเดิม และนั่นเป็นเพราะเราใช้เอกลักษณ์ตรีโกณมิติ สามตัวแรกเป็น
การจัดเรียงใหม่ของสูตรมุมสองเท่า ดังนั้นมุมถูกทำให้เป็นสองเท่าอย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ และตอนนี้เราพร้อมที่จะ
พูดถึง Block sphere แล้ว มาเน้นที่สัมประสิทธิ์สามตัวของเมทริกซ์ Pauli ที่ไม่ใช่เอกลักษณ์
ในตัวเศษของนิพจน์เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น ดังนั้นเราไม่สนใจสองในตัวหาร
เราไม่สนใจเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ด้วย เพราะสัมประสิทธิ์ตัวนั้นไม่เคยเปลี่ยน นั่นเกิดขึ้นเพราะ
สัมประสิทธิ์นั้นถูกกำหนดโดย trace ของเมทริกซ์ที่เราแสดง และเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นมี trace เท่ากับ
หนึ่งเสมอ ตอนนี้จินตนาการว่าเรามีสามแกนชื่อ x y และ z จัดวางตาม
กฎมือขวา และพิจารณาจุดที่พิกัดตรงกับสัมประสิทธิ์สามตัว และให้ชัดเจน นี่
คือปริภูมิสามมิติธรรมดาที่เรากำลังพูดถึง ที่พิกัดเป็นจำนวนจริงเสมอ
พิกัด x สอดคล้องกับสัมประสิทธิ์ของเมทริกซ์ Pauli sigma X ในตัวเศษของนิพจน์ ซึ่งเป็นจำนวนจริงเสมอเพราะเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
เป็นเอร์มิเชียน และเช่นเดียวกันสำหรับ Y และ Z สิ่งที่เราพบคือจุดที่
ได้อยู่บนทรงกลมหนึ่งหน่วยเสมอ หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือทรงกลมที่มีรัศมีเท่ากับ
หนึ่ง และโดยเฉพาะมันเป็นจุดที่ได้ถ้าเราเริ่มจากจุดที่แกน z บวกตัดทรงกลม
ซึ่งเราคิดได้ว่าเป็นขั้วเหนือ หมุนลงไปทางแกน x บวกเป็นมุม theta แล้ว
หมุนไปทางแกน y บวก หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือไปทางทิศตะวันออกเป็นมุม phi ในบริบทนี้มุม theta
เรียกว่ามุมโพลาร์ ซึ่งจำง่ายเพราะมันเริ่มจากขั้ว และ phi เรียกว่ามุม
แอซิมัทัล และทั้งสองมุมนี้แสดงพิกัดทรงกลมสำหรับจุดบนทรงกลมหนึ่งหน่วย และถ้า
ต้องการ ก็สามารถให้รัศมีเปลี่ยนแปลงได้เพื่อแสดงจุดใดก็ได้ในปริภูมิสามมิติ แต่ตรงนี้เราเน้นที่จุดบน
ทรงกลมหนึ่งหน่วยที่รัศมีเท่ากับหนึ่ง ยังสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ theta ว่าแสดงละติจูด ยกเว้นว่าไป
จาก 0 ถึง 180 องศาจากขั้วเหนือถึงขั้วใต้ แทนที่จะเป็นบวกลบ 90 องศาจากเส้นศูนย์สูตร และ phi แสดง
ลองจิจูด ที่เราบอกว่าเส้นเมริเดียนหลักคือเส้นที่ตัดแกน x
บวก ถ้าเหมือนเรา ที่มีปัญหาจำว่าอันไหนละติจูดอันไหนลองจิจูด อาจช่วยจำได้ว่า
ลองจิจูดสอดคล้องกับช่วงที่ยาวกว่า คือ 2 pi เทียบกับ
pi อย่างไรก็ตาม จุดที่เราได้บนทรงกลมหนึ่งหน่วยจากเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม qubit psi โดยคิดเกี่ยวกับพิกัดแบบนี้
คือการแสดง Block sphere ของสถานะควอนตัมที่สอดคล้องกับ psi และเมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
ทรงกลมหนึ่งหน่วยสามมิติทั้งหมดในแบบนี้ เราได้ Block sphere ในทางเรขาคณิตมันก็แค่ทรงกลม
หนึ่งหน่วยในปริภูมิสามมิติธรรมดา แต่จริงๆ แล้วนั่นคือเรขาคณิตของสถานะ
qubit มีการจับคู่หนึ่งต่อหนึ่งที่สมบูรณ์แบบ ทุกสถานะบริสุทธิ์ของ qubit สอดคล้องกับจุดบนทรงกลมที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์
และทุกจุดบนทรงกลมแสดงสถานะ qubit ที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์จนถึงเฟสรวม เมื่อเราทำงานกับ
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม การจับคู่นี้มีชื่ออื่นด้วย บางทีเรียกว่า Poincaré sphere
เช่นกัน แต่ในบริบทของข้อมูลควอนตัม มักเรียกว่า Block sphere สังเกตว่าตอนนี้เราเห็น
ความเสื่อมในมุม phi ได้ชัดเจน เพราะลองจิจูดไม่มีความหมายที่ขั้วเหนือและขั้วใต้ แต่นอกจาก
ขั้ว ทุกจุดบนโลกมีพิกัดที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์ในแง่ของละติจูดและลองจิจูด และสิ่งเดียวกันเกิดขึ้นที่นี่ นั่นคือวิธีที่
Block sphere ทำงานโดยทั่วไป ตอนนี้มาดูตัวอย่างเฉพาะบางอย่างของสถานะ qubit และ
ตำแหน่งของมันบน Block sphere มาเริ่มจากฐานมาตรฐาน นี่คือจุดที่ได้
เมื่อมุมโพลาร์ theta เป็นศูนย์สำหรับสถานะศูนย์ และ pi สำหรับสถานะหนึ่ง นี่คือสองกรณีที่
มุมแอซิมัทัล phi ไม่เกี่ยว ดังที่พูดไปแล้ว เราสามารถแสดงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่สอดคล้องกันเป็นการรวม
เชิงเส้นของเมทริกซ์ Pauli ได้ด้วย ไม่ว่าจะวิธีไหน เราสรุปว่าสองสถานะนี้สอดคล้องกับขั้วเหนือและ
ขั้วใต้ของ Block sphere สถานะศูนย์อยู่ด้านบนและสถานะหนึ่งอยู่ด้าน
ล่าง ต่อไปมาหาสถานะ plus และ minus บน Block sphere อีกครั้งเราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมหรือเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น สำหรับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม คราวนี้มุมโพลาร์ theta ต้องเป็น pi
หาร 2 เพื่อให้สมาชิกที่ศูนย์เป็น 1 หาร รากที่สองของ 2 มุมแอซิมัทัล phi ต้องเป็นศูนย์
สำหรับสถานะ plus เพราะสมาชิกที่หนึ่งเป็นบวก และต้องเป็น pi หรือ 180 องศาสำหรับสถานะ minus
เพราะตัวนั้นเป็นลบ ดังนั้นจุดสองจุดนี้อยู่บน
เส้นศูนย์สูตรของ Block sphere สถานะ plus อยู่ที่แกน x บวกตัดทรงกลม และสถานะ minus อยู่ฝั่งตรงข้ามที่
แกน x ลบตัดทรงกลม เทียบเท่ากัน เราสามารถเห็นจากนิพจน์เมทริกซ์ Pauli สำหรับ
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่สอดคล้องกันว่าพิกัด Y และ Z เป็นศูนย์ทั้งคู่ ในขณะที่พิกัด x เป็นบวกและลบ
1 อีกตัวอย่างหนึ่งคือฐาน plus i minus i ซึ่งคล้ายฐาน plus minus ยกเว้นว่าเราคูณสมาชิก
ที่หนึ่งด้วย i หน่วยจินตภาพ เราเห็นสถานะ plus i ก่อนหน้านี้ในบทเรียน และสถานะ minus i นิยาม
ในทำนองเดียวกัน มุมโพลาร์ theta เหมือนกับสถานะ plus และ minus คือ pi
หาร 2 และคราวนี้เราต้องเลือกมุมแอซิมัทัล phi ให้ได้ i และลบ i แทน 1 และลบ 1
และ pi หาร 2 กับ 3 pi หาร 2 เป็นตัวเลือกที่ถูกต้อง อีกครั้งเราสามารถดู
การอธิบายเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของสถานะเหล่านี้ และสิ่งต่างๆ คล้ายกับสองตัวอย่างก่อนหน้า ยกเว้นคราวนี้เป็นเมทริกซ์ Pauli Y แทน
Z หรือ X ดังนั้นบน Block sphere สถานะสองตัวนี้อยู่ที่แกน y
ตัดทรงกลม และถ้าเราจัดให้เรียบร้อย เราจะเห็นชัดขึ้นว่าหกสถานะที่เราเพิ่งพูดถึง
สัมพันธ์กันยังไง สำหรับอีกตัวอย่างหนึ่ง หรือจริงๆ แล้วเป็นกลุ่มตัวอย่าง ลองพิจารณา
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม qubit ที่เกิดขึ้นก่อนหน้านี้และในบทเรียนที่สี่ ที่สมาชิกที่ศูนย์คือ cosine ของ alpha สำหรับจำนวนจริง alpha และสมาชิกที่หนึ่ง
คือ sine ของ alpha เราสามารถจำกัดความสนใจไปที่ค่า alpha ระหว่างศูนย์ถึง pi เพราะค่า
alpha อื่นจะให้เวกเตอร์ที่เทียบเท่าจนถึงเฟสรวมกับตัวที่ alpha อยู่ใน
ช่วงนี้ ถ้าเราคำนวณเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่สัมพันธ์กับสถานะเหล่านี้ แสดงเป็นการรวมเชิงเส้นของเมทริกซ์ Pauli
เราจะได้นิพจน์ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ การคำนวณไม่ได้แสดงที่นี่ แต่นั่นคือสิ่งที่ควร
ได้ถ้าคำนวณเอง และสิ่งที่พบคือสถานะเหล่านี้ก่อตัวเป็นวงกลมใหญ่ที่ผ่าน
ขั้ว โดยเฉพาะเริ่มจากขั้วเหนือเมื่อ alpha เป็นศูนย์ ลงมาตามเส้นเมริเดียนหลัก และ
ถึงขั้วใต้เมื่อ alpha เป็น pi หาร 2 แล้วกลับไปขั้วเหนือฝั่งตรงข้ามของทรงกลมเมื่อ alpha เปลี่ยนจาก pi หาร 2 ถึง
pi และทั้งหมดสมเหตุสมผลเพราะหนึ่ง เหล่านี้เป็นเวกเตอร์จริง ดังนั้นส่วนจินตภาพเป็นศูนย์เสมอ และสอง
มุม alpha ถูกทำให้เป็นสองเท่าบน Block sphere อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ และอีกครั้งอธิบายได้จากการใช้
สูตรมุมสองเท่า เราเห็นว่า Block sphere ให้การแสดงทางเรขาคณิตที่ดีมากสำหรับสถานะบริสุทธิ์ของ
qubit ที่แต่ละจุดบนทรงกลมสอดคล้องกับสถานะบริสุทธิ์ที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์ของ qubit และกลับกัน
เมื่อเราพูดถึง Block ball เราหมายถึงจุดทั้งหมดบน Block sphere รวมถึงจุด
ที่อยู่ภายในด้วย จุดภายในของ Block ball ก็สอดคล้องกับสถานะ qubit เช่นกัน
โดยเฉพาะสถานะที่ไม่ใช่สถานะบริสุทธิ์ พูดอีกอย่างคือสถานะ qubit ที่สามารถแสดงด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแต่ไม่ใช่ด้วยเวกเตอร์สถานะ
qubit ด้านพื้นฐานของ Block ball และวิธีที่จุดภายในแสดงสถานะที่ไม่บริสุทธิ์คือ
การรวมแบบนูนของจุดภายใน Block ball สอดคล้องกับการรวมแบบนูนของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
พูดเชิงสัญชาตญาณ หมายความว่าเรขาคณิตยังคงทำงานสมบูรณ์แบบแม้ภายใน Block
ball มาดูตัวอย่างสองสามตัว เริ่มจากจุดศูนย์กลางของ Block ball ซึ่งแสดง
สถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ สถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ได้จากการเฉลี่ยสถานะศูนย์และหนึ่ง ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า
จุดศูนย์กลางของทรงกลมอยู่กึ่งกลางพอดีระหว่างขั้วเหนือและขั้วใต้ และจริงๆ แล้วมันอยู่กึ่งกลางระหว่างจุดตรงข้ามใดก็ได้ เช่น
สถานะ plus และ minus และสถานะ plus i และ minus i จุดตรงข้ามบน Block sphere สอดคล้องกับ
สถานะบริสุทธิ์ที่ตั้งฉากกันเสมอ และสิ่งนี้เปิดเผยหรือสะท้อนว่าเราสามารถเขียนสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์
เป็นค่าเฉลี่ยระหว่างสถานะบริสุทธิ์ qubit ที่ตั้งฉากกันสองตัวใดก็ได้เสมอ อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการเห็นนี้คือ
คิดเกี่ยวกับการแสดงเมทริกซ์ Pauli ของสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ เพื่อให้ได้ผล เราต้องตั้ง
สัมประสิทธิ์ของเมทริกซ์ Pauli ที่ไม่ใช่เอกลักษณ์ทั้งสามตัวเป็นศูนย์ และจุดที่สอดคล้องกันภายใน
Block ball จึงอยู่ตรงกลางที่จุดกำเนิด และอีกอย่าง การคิดเกี่ยวกับการแสดงเมทริกซ์ Pauli ของเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่นแบบนี้ทำให้เห็นค่อนข้างชัดว่าการรวมแบบนูนของจุด Block ball สอดคล้องกับการรวมแบบนูน
ของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น ถ้าเราเฉลี่ยหรือถ่วงน้ำหนักเฉลี่ยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นและ
แสดงทุกอย่างในรูปการรวมเชิงเส้นของเมทริกซ์ Pauli ก็แน่นอนว่าเราแค่เฉลี่ยจุดที่สอดคล้องกัน เพราะทุกอย่าง
เป็นเชิงเส้นในสัมประสิทธิ์สามตัวนั้น สำหรับอีกตัวอย่างหนึ่ง มาพิจารณาค่าเฉลี่ยของสถานะศูนย์
กับสถานะ plus ที่เราเห็นก่อนหน้านี้ในบทเรียน เราคำนวณเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแล้ว ดังที่แสดง
บนหน้าจอ และเราเห็นว่าจุดอยู่ภายใน Block ball ตรงกึ่งกลางระหว่างสถานะศูนย์กับสถานะ
plus เรายังเห็นว่าสามารถแสดงเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นนี้ในอีกวิธีจากการแยกสเปกตรัล และ
อีกครั้ง สอดคล้องกับแผนภาพและตัวอย่างก่อนหน้า และนั่นคือจบ
การพูดถึง Block sphere และ Block ball คนมักถามว่ามี Block sphere หรือ Block ball สำหรับระบบที่มี
สามหรือมากกว่าสถานะคลาสสิกไหม และคำตอบที่น่าเสียดายคือไม่จริงหรอก เราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ
สถานะควอนตัมของระบบในเชิงเรขาคณิตคล้ายกับ Block ball เสมอ และเราจะได้วัตถุนูนในปริภูมิเวกเตอร์จริง
แต่ถ้ามีสามหรือมากกว่าสถานะคลาสสิก มันจะไม่เป็นทรงกลม ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้ามี
สถานะคลาสสิกสามตัวพอดี หรือ qutrit จะได้วัตถุนูนในปริภูมิแปดมิติ
แต่จุดสุดขีดของวัตถุนั้น ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับสถานะควอนตัมบริสุทธิ์ของ qutrit จะเป็นแค่
สี่มิติ ถ้าจินตนาการได้ว่าเอาแมนิโฟลด์สี่มิติในปริภูมิแปดมิติมาห่อด้วยพลาสติกหดเพื่อได้วัตถุ
นูน แล้วพบว่ามันเป็นวิธีที่มีประโยชน์ในการคิดเกี่ยวกับ qutrit ก็เยี่ยมเลย มันน่าสนใจที่
จะคิด แต่มันไม่ใช่ลูกบอล มันซับซ้อนกว่านั้น ในส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียน เราจะพูดสั้นๆ ว่า
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นทำงานยังไงสำหรับหลายระบบ เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นสามารถแสดงสถานะของหลายระบบ และนี่
ทำงานในแบบที่คล้ายคลึงกับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมทุกประการ โดยเฉพาะเหมือนที่เรามีในสูตรแบบง่ายของข้อมูล
ควอนตัม เราสามารถมองหลายระบบรวมกันราวกับเป็นระบบรวมเดียว
คราวนี้ทั้งแถวและคอลัมน์ของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่แสดงสถานะของหลายระบบ
ถูกจับคู่กับผลคูณคาร์ทีเซียนของเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของแต่ละระบบ ตัวอย่างเช่น เราสามารถพิจารณา
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของสถานะ Bell ทั้งสี่ ซึ่งได้มาเหมือนที่ทำกับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมอื่นๆ
ก่อนหน้านี้ในบทเรียน โดยคูณเวกเตอร์สถานะกับสังยุคทรานสโพส และผลลัพธ์แสดงบน
หน้าจอ โดยพื้นฐานแล้วไม่มีอะไรใหม่ในระดับแนวคิด แม้ว่าเราจะเห็นในอีกสักครู่ว่ามี
สิ่งใหม่ที่ทำได้กับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นสำหรับหลายระบบ แนวคิดของความเป็นอิสระและ
ความสัมพันธ์ส่งผ่านจากเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมไปยังเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น และโดยเฉพาะเราพบว่าผลคูณเทนเซอร์
ของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแสดงความเป็นอิสระระหว่างระบบ เราใช้ศัพท์เดียวกัน
กับที่ใช้สำหรับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้ามีระบบ X ที่เตรียมในสถานะ rho และระบบ Y
ที่เตรียมอย่างอิสระในสถานะ sigma สถานะของคู่ XY รวมกันกำหนดโดยผลคูณเทนเซอร์
ของ rho และ sigma เราเรียกสิ่งนี้ว่าสถานะผลคูณ และนี่ขยายไปสู่มากกว่าสอง
ระบบอย่างเป็นธรรมชาติ เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่ไม่สามารถแสดงเป็นสถานะผลคูณได้แสดงถึงความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างระบบ และส่วน
นั้นคล้ายกับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม แต่ปรากฏว่ามีความสัมพันธ์หลายประเภทที่เกิดขึ้นได้เมื่อใช้เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น แม้แค่
สองระบบ ในทางตรงกันข้าม มีแค่ประเภทเดียวของความสัมพันธ์สำหรับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม และ
นั่นคือการพัวพัน พูดอีกอย่าง ความสัมพันธ์และการพัวพันเป็นคำพ้องความหมายสำหรับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม แต่
สำหรับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นมันไม่จริง ที่นี่สิ่งต่างๆ น่าสนใจกว่า ตัวอย่างเช่น เราสามารถอธิบาย
สถานะคลาสสิกที่มีความสัมพันธ์กันด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น นี่คือตัวอย่างของเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่แสดงบิตสุ่มแบบคลาสสิก
ที่แชร์ระหว่าง Alice กับ Bob ทั้งสองมีสถานะคลาสสิกเดียวกันเสมอ คือศูนย์หรือหนึ่ง และความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับ
1/2 สำหรับแต่ละกรณี นี่ไม่ใช่สถานะพัวพัน การพัวพันเป็นเรื่องไม่คลาสสิก แต่
มันเป็นสถานะที่มีความสัมพันธ์กัน อีกตัวอย่างหนึ่งเชื่อมโยงกับแนวคิดของ ensemble ของสถานะควอนตัม
ซึ่งคิดได้ว่าเป็นการแจกแจงความน่าจะเป็นบนเซตจำกัดของสถานะควอนตัม โดยเฉพาะลองจินตนาการว่า
เรามีเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น m ตัว rho ศูนย์ถึง rho m ลบหนึ่ง ทั้งหมดแสดงสถานะที่เป็นไปได้ของระบบหนึ่ง
พร้อมกับความน่าจะเป็นที่จะสุ่มเลือกแต่ละตัว ถ้าต้องการเราสามารถคำนวณค่าเฉลี่ยถ่วงน้ำหนักของเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่นเหล่านี้โดยเอาการรวมแบบนูนของมัน แต่นั่นจะไม่บอกเราว่าแต่ละสถานะคืออะไรหรือ
ความน่าจะเป็นเท่าไหร่ สิ่งที่ทำได้แทน และมันมีประโยชน์มากบางครั้ง คือพิจารณาเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่นในรูปแบบที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ นี่คือสถานะของสองระบบ ที่ระบบแรกมีสถานะคลาสสิก
หนึ่งตัวสำหรับแต่ละทางเลือก และเราเอาค่าเฉลี่ยถ่วงน้ำหนักของสถานะผลคูณ m ตัว ที่สถานะของ
ระบบแรกเป็นคลาสสิกเสมอ และทำหน้าที่เป็นป้ายกำกับว่าเรามีสถานะไหนจาก m สถานะสำหรับระบบ
ที่สอง ถ้ายังไม่ชัดว่าทำไมถึงอยากคิดเกี่ยวกับสถานะแบบนี้ ก็ไม่เป็นไร มันเป็นแค่ตัวอย่างของ
ประเภทของความสัมพันธ์ที่ระบบแรกเป็นคลาสสิกเสมอ และระบบที่สองอาจอยู่ในสถานะ
ควอนตัม ประเภทที่สามของสถานะที่อาจมีความสัมพันธ์คือเซตของสถานะที่เรียกว่า
แยกได้ พูดง่ายๆ คือมันเป็นการรวมแบบนูนของสถานะผลคูณ และมันแสดงสถานะควอนตัม
ที่ความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างระบบเป็นความสัมพันธ์แบบคลาสสิก วิธีหนึ่งในการคิดเกี่ยวกับ
สถานะแบบนี้คือเราสุ่มเลือกค่า k แล้วเตรียมสองระบบอย่างอิสระ
ในสถานะควอนตัมที่ขึ้นอยู่กับการเลือก k สิ่งที่น่าสนใจที่สุดเกี่ยวกับ
สถานะในรูปแบบนี้คือนี่คือวิธีที่เรานิยามการพัวพันในทางคณิตศาสตร์ โดยเฉพาะการพัวพันคือ
การนิยามว่าเป็นการขาดความสามารถในการแยกได้ ดังนั้นถ้ามีเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแล้วไม่สามารถแสดงมันในรูปแบบ
แบบนี้ได้ ตามนิยามมันเป็นสถานะพัวพัน พูดถึงเรื่องนี้ไว้ในบทเรียนที่สี่ และนี่คือรายละเอียด
เพิ่มเติม อีกอย่าง มันยากมากที่จะหาว่าเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่กำหนดให้แสดงสถานะพัวพัน
หรือเปล่า แม้จะมีคอมพิวเตอร์ช่วย ในทางคณิตศาสตร์และการคำนวณ การพัวพันเป็นเรื่อง
ที่ซับซ้อนจริงๆ พูดไว้ตอนต้นบทเรียนว่ามีสิ่งสำคัญมากที่ทำได้กับเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น และ
นั่นคือการอธิบายสถานะของส่วนที่แยกออกมาของระบบ แม้ว่ามันจะมีความสัมพันธ์และอาจพัวพันกับระบบ
อื่น คำว่าสถานะลดรูปมักใช้ในบริบทนี้ และเป็นตัวอย่างง่ายๆ เราจะคำนวณสถานะลดรูป
ของ qubit แต่ละตัวที่ประกอบเป็น ebit พูดให้แม่นยำ สมมติว่า
Alice กับ Bob แชร์ ebit Alice ถือ qubit A Bob ถือ qubit B และ qubit ทั้งสองรวมกันอยู่ในสถานะ
phi plus และคำถามที่เราจะตอบคือสถานะของ qubit A ของ Alice
โดยลำพังคืออะไร แน่นอนว่าถามคำถามเดียวกันสำหรับ qubit ของ Bob ก็ได้ แต่ง่ายที่จะตอบเมื่อรู้คำตอบแล้ว
อาจอยากจะบอกว่าไม่สามารถอธิบายสถานะของ qubit ของ Alice โดยลำพังได้เพราะมัน
พัวพันกับ qubit ของ Bob ซึ่งอาจห้ามเราจากการอธิบายหรือแม้แต่คิดเกี่ยวกับสถานะของ A
โดยลำพัง แต่นี่ไม่จริง จริงอยู่ว่าเราไม่สามารถอธิบายสถานะของ A ด้วยเวกเตอร์สถานะ
ควอนตัม เพราะอย่างที่จะเห็น มันไม่ได้อยู่ในสถานะบริสุทธิ์ แต่ทุกระบบมีสถานะ ณ เวลาใดก็ได้ ที่สามารถ
อธิบายด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น ไม่ว่ามันจะพัวพันกับระบบอื่นหรือไม่ เป็นการทดลองทางความคิด เพื่อช่วย
ให้เราเห็นว่าคำตอบของคำถามนี้คืออะไร สมมติว่า Bob ตัดสินใจเอา qubit ของเขาเดินทางไปดวงดาว และไม่มีใครได้ยินข่าวจากเขา
อีกเลย แต่จินตนาการว่าระหว่างทางเขาตัดสินใจทำการวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐานบน
qubit ของเขา เรารู้วิธีคำนวณความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับสองผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้ และเรายังรู้ว่า
สถานะของ A จะเป็นอะไรสำหรับแต่ละผลลัพธ์ และสิ่งเหล่านั้นสรุปในตารางนี้ โดยเฉพาะด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2
A จะเหลืออยู่ในสถานะศูนย์ และด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 A จะเหลืออยู่ในสถานะหนึ่ง และอย่างที่พูดไว้ก่อนหน้า
ในบทเรียน นี่ทำให้ A อยู่ในสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ และดังนั้นนั่นคือคำตอบ
ของคำถาม อาจจะค้านว่านี่ขึ้นอยู่กับข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า
Bob ตัดสินใจวัด qubit ของเขา และสมมติฐานที่ว่าเขาทำเป็นส่วนหนึ่งของเรื่องที่นำเราไปสู่คำตอบ แต่
ถ้า Bob อยู่ห่างหลายปีแสงเมื่อเขาวัด ไม่มีสิ่งใดที่เขาทำจะมีอิทธิพลต่อ
การทดลองใดก็ตามที่ Alice อาจตัดสินใจทำบน qubit ของเธอ ไม่อย่างนั้นเราจะมีการสื่อสารเร็วกว่า
แสง ดังนั้น qubit ของ Alice อยู่ในสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ ไม่ว่า Bob จะ
วัดหรือไม่ ควรบอกชัดเจนว่าแนวคิดของสถานะลดรูปและวิธีนิยามมันไม่ได้ขึ้นอยู่กับสัมพัทธภาพ
หรือความเป็นไปไม่ได้ของการสื่อสารเร็วกว่าแสง นี่เป็นแค่วิธีอธิบายมันในแง่ที่หวังว่าจะเข้าใจได้ง่าย
จริงๆ แล้วมีนิยามทางคณิตศาสตร์ ซึ่งเราจะเห็นในบริบทที่ทั่วไปกว่าในอีกสักครู่ มันสอดคล้องกับคำตอบนี้
และบังเอิญกับความเป็นไปไม่ได้ของการสื่อสารเร็วกว่าแสง และไม่มีนิยามอื่น
ที่สามารถสอดคล้องกับข้อมูลควอนตัมอย่างที่เรารู้ ตอนนี้มาพิจารณาสถานะลดรูปอย่าง
ทั่วไปมากขึ้น สมมติว่าเรามีคู่ระบบ A และ B ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็น qubit ที่รวมกันอยู่ในสถานะบริสุทธิ์
แสดงด้วยเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม psi อีกครั้งเราจะเน้นที่สถานะลดรูปของระบบ A และเพื่อทำ
สิ่งนี้ จะเป็นประโยชน์ที่จะคิดเกี่ยวกับสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบ B ดังนั้นให้ gamma เป็นเซตของ
สถานะคลาสสิกของ B อย่างที่เราพูดไว้ก่อนหน้า ในบทเรียนที่สองของซีรีส์เป็นต้น
มีชุดเวกเตอร์ phi b สำหรับแต่ละ b ใน gamma ที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์ ที่นิพจน์ของ psi ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ
ถูกต้อง และโดยเฉพาะมีสูตรง่ายๆ สำหรับเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้ เราแค่คูณเวกเตอร์ psi ด้วย
ผลคูณเทนเซอร์ของเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ที่สอดคล้องกับระบบ A กับ bra b สำหรับ b ใดก็ตามที่สนใจ
สิ่งที่เราทำคือเตรียมตัวคำนวณว่าจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้าเราทำ
การวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐานบน B และอีกครั้ง เรื่องนี้ถูกกล่าวถึงในบทเรียนที่สองของ
การวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐานบน B และอีกครั้ง เรื่องนี้พูดไว้ในบทเรียนที่สองของ
ซีรีส์ สมมติว่าเราทำการวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐานบน B แต่ละผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้จะ
ปรากฏด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับนอร์มยูคลิเดียนยกกำลังสองของเวกเตอร์ phi b ที่สอดคล้องกัน และเมื่อได้ผลลัพธ์
b หนึ่ง เรานอร์มัลไลซ์เวกเตอร์ phi b เพื่อกำหนดสถานะที่ได้ของ
A ตามเหตุผลเดียวกันกับในตัวอย่าง ebit เมื่อกี้ เราได้นิพจน์ที่แสดงบน
หน้าจอสำหรับสถานะลดรูปของ A ในรูปเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น และอีกอย่าง นอร์มยกกำลังสองในตัวหารมาจาก
การคูณเวกเตอร์ที่นอร์มัลไลซ์กับสังยุคทรานสโพสของมัน ดังนั้นเราได้นอร์มยูคลิเดียนสองครั้งใน
ตัวหาร นอร์มยูคลิเดียนยกกำลังสองตัดกัน และเราเหลือนิพจน์ที่ค่อนข้าง
ง่าย และจริงๆ ถ้าเราแทนสูตรของ phi b ซึ่งใช้ได้สำหรับทุก b เราจะได้สูตรของสถานะลดรูป
ของระบบ A ในรูปเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นของสถานะบริสุทธิ์ที่เราเริ่มต้น คือ ket psi
bra psi นี่คือสูตรของสถานะลดรูปของระบบ A สมมติว่าระบบรวม AB เริ่มใน
สถานะบริสุทธิ์ psi แต่เราสามารถใช้สูตรนี้ทั่วไปกว่านั้นได้ โดยเฉพาะสมมติ
ว่าสถานะของ AB กำหนดโดยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น rho ซึ่งอาจอยู่ในรูป ket psi bra psi สำหรับเวกเตอร์สถานะ
ควอนตัม psi แต่ไม่จำเป็น ตามมาจากความเป็นเชิงเส้นว่าสถานะลดรูปของ A
กำหนดโดยสูตรเดียวกันกับที่มีสำหรับสถานะบริสุทธิ์ ยกเว้นว่าเราแทนเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น rho ใดก็ได้
ที่ต้องการ เป็นสัญกรณ์ย่อ มันเป็นเรื่องปกติที่จะเรียกสถานะลดรูปนี้ด้วยชื่อที่เราใช้สำหรับ
เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น rho ในกรณีนี้ แต่ใส่ตัวห้อยที่ระบุระบบที่เราเน้น ดังนั้น rho กับ
ตัวห้อย A หมายถึงสถานะลดรูปของ A เมื่อระบบรวมอยู่ในสถานะ rho ตัวยกบนบางทีก็ใช้
แทนตัวห้อย มันก็แค่ความชอบส่วนตัว และมีความหมายเหมือนกัน
เราเน้นที่ระบบ A เพื่อความง่าย แต่เราสามารถหาสถานะลดรูปของระบบ B ได้
ในทำนองเดียวกัน แต่สูตรปรับให้เหมาะสมตามธรรมชาติ ทุกอย่างสมมาตรที่นี่ เรา
แค่สลับบทบาทของ A และ B และโดยเฉพาะผลรวมครอบคลุมสถานะคลาสสิกของ A คราวนี้
แทนที่จะเป็น B และในสูตรบนหน้าจอ เราสมมติว่าเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของ A เรียกว่า
Sigma ทั้งหมดนี้ขยายไปสู่สามระบบหรือมากกว่าได้อย่างตรงไปตรงมา ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้ามีสาม
ระบบ A B และ C ที่รวมกันอยู่ในสถานะที่อธิบายด้วยเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น rho เราสามารถหา
สถานะลดรูปของคู่ AB รวมกันด้วยสูตรที่แสดง รวมถึงสถานะของระบบที่สามเดี่ยว
ซึ่งเป็นสูตรที่สอง และสามารถพิจารณาการรวมกันอื่นๆ และขยายไปสู่กี่ระบบก็ได้ตามต้องการ ผลรวมจะรวมเสมอ
บนเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบที่ถูกละเลย และรูปแบบเหมือนกันเสมอ กับเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่นที่เริ่มต้นถูกประกบระหว่างผลคูณเทนเซอร์ของเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์กับ bra และ ket ที่สอดคล้องกับสถานะฐาน
มาตรฐาน เพื่อปิดท้ายบทเรียน จะพูดเพิ่มอีกเล็กน้อยเกี่ยวกับนิยามที่เราเพิ่งพูดถึง การดำเนินการบนเมทริกซ์
ความหนาแน่นที่อธิบายสถานะลดรูปมีชื่อเรียกว่า partial trace สำหรับสองระบบ A และ B
partial trace บน B และ partial trace บน A เป็นดังที่นิยามบนหน้าจอ นี่เป็นสูตรเดียวกัน
ที่เราเห็นเมื่อกี้ และตอนนี้เราแค่คิดเกี่ยวกับมันเป็นฟังก์ชันของ rho และตั้งชื่อให้
ชื่อดูเหมือน trace ยกเว้นว่ามีตัวห้อยที่บอกว่าระบบไหนถูกเอาออก
หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือระบบไหนที่เซตสถานะคลาสสิกของมันถูกรวมผลบวก และถูกประกบระหว่าง bra กับ
ket เมื่อเราทำ partial trace บน B เช่น ซึ่งอธิบายโดยสูตรแรก เราบางทีบอกว่า
B ถูก trace ออก และเช่นเดียวกันสำหรับ A พูดเชิงสัญชาตญาณ การ trace ระบบออก
ก็แค่หมายความว่าเราทิ้งมันไปหรือไม่สนใจมัน นั่นคือวิธีหนึ่งในการนิยาม partial
trace และอีกวิธีที่เทียบเท่าคือบอกว่าการส่งเหล่านี้เป็นการส่งเชิงเส้นที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์ที่สอดคล้องกับ
สูตรที่แสดงทางขวา โดยเฉพาะ ถ้ามีผลคูณเทนเซอร์ของเมทริกซ์สองตัว M และ N
และเราทำ partial trace บนระบบแรก สิ่งที่ได้คือ trace ของเมทริกซ์แรก M คูณ
เมทริกซ์ที่สอง และเงื่อนไขเป็นแบบสมมาตรเมื่อ trace บนระบบที่สอง ไม่ใช่ทุกเมทริกซ์ที่
คำนวณ partial trace จะเป็นผลคูณเทนเซอร์แบบนี้ แต่ทุกเมทริกซ์สามารถแสดงเป็นการรวมเชิงเส้นของ
ผลคูณเทนเซอร์ และเราสามารถกำหนด partial trace จากเงื่อนไขเหล่านี้ร่วมกับความจริงที่ว่าเป็นฟังก์ชัน
เชิงเส้น และนี่คือเหตุผลที่มันเรียกว่า partial trace นิยามที่เทียบเท่านี้สามารถ
มีประโยชน์มากเพราะเราสามารถใช้มันแทนสูตรเดิมได้บ่อย นี่คือตัวอย่างที่
แสดงเรื่องนี้ สมมติว่าเรามี qubit คู่หนึ่งในสถานะที่เมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นแสดงบน
หน้าจอ นี่บังเอิญเป็นตัวอย่างของสถานะที่มีความสัมพันธ์ ที่ A เป็นสถานะศูนย์หรือสถานะหนึ่ง แต่ละตัว
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 ดังนั้นคิดได้ว่า A เป็นแบบคลาสสิก ถ้า A อยู่ในสถานะศูนย์
B ก็เป็นเช่นกัน และถ้า A อยู่ในสถานะหนึ่ง B จะอยู่ในสถานะ plus ถ้าต้องการรู้สถานะลดรูปของ A
เรา trace B ออก และถ้าใช้สูตรที่สองจากนิยามที่เทียบเท่าร่วมกับความเป็นเชิงเส้น เราสามารถ
คำนวณได้ง่ายมาก โดยเฉพาะ trace ของ ket 0 bra 0 เท่ากับหนึ่ง เช่นเดียวกับ trace ของ ket plus bra
plus ดังนั้นตัวคูณเทนเซอร์เหล่านั้นหายไป และเราเหลือสถานะผสมสมบูรณ์ ในทำนองเดียวกัน เราสามารถคำนวณ
สถานะลดรูปของ B โดย trace A ออก คราวนี้เป็นตัวคูณเทนเซอร์แรกที่เราทำ trace ดังนั้น
เราใช้สูตรแรกจากนิยามที่เทียบเท่า และเราเหลือ 1/2 คูณ ket 0 bra 0 บวก 1/2 คูณ ket
plus bra plus หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นเดียวกันที่เกิดขึ้นหลายครั้งก่อนหน้านี้ จะได้ผลลัพธ์เดียวกัน
ทุกประการถ้าใช้สูตรจากนิยามแรก แต่นี่เป็นวิธีที่ง่ายกว่ามาก ทั้งหมดนี้ขยายไปสู่สามระบบหรือมากกว่า
แต่สำหรับวิดีโอนี้จะหยุดแค่นี้ และเหลือให้ลองคิดเอง และนั่นคือจบบทเรียนนี้ ซึ่ง
ได้แนะนำเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นและอธิบายพื้นฐานของการทำงานของมัน เรายังพูดถึง Block sphere
รวมถึงความสัมพันธ์ประเภทต่างๆ และแนวคิดของสถานะลดรูปของระบบ หวังว่าจะมาร่วมฟัง
บทเรียนต่อไป ซึ่งเป็นเรื่องของช่องทาง ซึ่งเป็นการส่งเชิงเส้นจากเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นไปยังเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่นที่
อธิบายการดำเนินการบนระบบ ลาก่อนจนกว่าจะพบกัน
อีกครั้ง